what's on tap it's the angels and the
white sox and all things are all about
show a ohtani as show a otani is the
first player in 118 years to be the
starting pitcher in a game and bat
second in that same game joey otani is
the single most interesting athlete in
the world for what he's trying to do
right now and we will finally see it on
display tonight against the very good
white sox two balls and two strikes
starts the night against tim anderson
on the ground back up the middle
that's david fletcher to make the play
from second base for the first down of
the night let's take you back to tim
anderson hitting the bag at first base
on that close play good way to roll an
ankle adam eaton now will stand in 2-2
101.
used to be that
94-95 was like wow that's amazing 94.95
is almost ho-hum now
in the big leagues 101 is still going to
grab your eyeballs here's the 2-2
got him to chum on that splitter
you speed up a batter and then you throw
a 92 mile an hour
split that just falls off the table look
at this baby leary garcia's taking over
at shortstop because it looks like
whatever happened to tim anderson as he
hit the bag at first base to start the
ball game has cost him the rest of the
night this is the first time that
american league team has willingly given
up a dh since 1976.
and first pitch crushing
oh man
lean into it
ohtani the hitter gets one out of sight
it's one nothing angels matty we said it
at the start i mean here's a guy that
throws the ball 101
on one half of the inning and the next
one is the first pitch
95 plus
450 feet
i mean that ball was crushed wow that
was ridiculous sucked up out here the
tail of the tape on that home run
451 it was a laser beam the bases are
now loaded so here is upton and upton
swings and lifts a high fly ball into
right field this one is going to carry
eaton to the rim of the track will make
the catch
a couple of the runners will tag and
coming in and scoring on that sac fly
will be mike trout and the angels have a
two-nothing lead his fourth rbi in this
series
two outs in the inning adam eaton who
struck out on a nasty split finger
fastballs first time up will be the
batter here's the next one it's bounced
between the legs of ohtani but there to
stop a near second is iglesias and he
will throw him out eaton is retired and
that's it for the white sox they had the
lead off single by the speedster
hamilton but he's stranded at second
shohei ohtani getting ready to face the
number three hitter in the white sock
lineup jose brayu got him four for
shohei otani tonight i mean the last two
pitchers here absolutely clinic here
here's the last one the split finger
maybe the best one of the night tumbling
out looks like a fastball and it's not
got him again the first time it was the
split finger this time as a slider and a
good one tight luis robert will be the
next battery with two outs and he got
him on the splitter there and boy this
strikeout for shohei in four innings two
on and we'll see if david fletcher can
come through poke shot in the right
field it's gonna fall in for a base hit
the lead runner iglesias will score
runners at the corners and that is david
fletcher's first rbi of the season
you'll love them when they come with two
outs it's three-nothing angels and
here's ohtani now in a position to
inflict some real harm there's a roller
toward the middle
and it's the shortstop garcia right
behind second to field it and he throws
to first to get otani
billy hamilton will be the batter that's
a shot into right center field and
making a diving catch on that one is
lagarus
he can play defense we know that we saw
it in spring training he's won a gold
glove in the past in the big leagues he
can play defense that's out number one
so that brings the tying run to the
plate in the form of the reigning
american league mvp looks like this is
going to be otani's hitter and he did
come in with a breaking ball and he
misses low and outside sea is ready to
go but this once again will be ohtani's
plate appearance and let him get out of
the bases loaded jam best opportunity
best and first opportunity the white sox
have had a yanks one and that's going to
get chicago on the scoreboard
that pitch was a splitter that bounced
in and got away from stassi and now
let's say 3-1 angels lead
the next 3-2
he got him
stacy's got to finish with the throw to
first base and it's mishandled fletcher
throws home that's wide ohtani goes down
at the plate the white sox score but a
much greater import is the health of
shohei otani
abreu he's a big guy slides into home
plate and shohei is standing on home
plate it was there's nothing abraham
could do as shohei jumped up to catch
this ball that will put an end to shohei
otani's otherwise extraordinary night
mike trout wearing a microphone for us
tonight throw him a fastball he won't
hit it you don't have to do the fastball
he will not miss a basketball walsh is
over one with a walk a 3-3 ball game
here at the big a walsh with a swing and
a drive and a ball
now the white sox played the matchup
they thought they made the right move to
counter the power hitting lefty
and jared walsh makes that move blow up
in their faces you mean mercedes in a
one run game 8th inning jammed
roller to third bare-handed pick by
rendon throw to first in time no no no
no missing the white sox are going to
challenge this oh yeah he's safe
we have a man on first yes we do
that is a record-setting infield hit for
your main mercedes that sex that sets a
white sox record
for most hits
through his first three career games
tying run is at second
one out in the ninth angels trying to
hold on to this 4-3 lead
back to the mound and iglesias
and the white sox
he saw the base runner though
madrigal halfway to
third he threw to third base they would
have got him if it was a good throw but
it was a terrible throw and now it's a
4-4 game the winning run at second and
jared walsh will be the next batter
left center field
[Applause]
he went to jared
what a finish
a two-home run night by jared walsh
it's the other two-way player
that wins the night